the white guilt never ends
even for the creator of friends
yeah she turned on the sitcom she built
to satisfy her caucasian guilt
marta kaufman the co-creator of friends
says she's embarrassed by the show's
lack of diversity
and she's pledging four million bucks to
brandon's university to support its
african-american studies department
kaufman also regrets her original name
for the series which was white people
are awesome
i could have warned her on that one
the show starred six best buds living in
west village apartments they could never
afford in real life it became a huge
success paving the way for such amazing
spin-offs
like joey
said kaufman in a recent interview i've
learned a lot in the last 20 years
admitting and accepting guilt is not
easy it's painful looking at yourself in
the mirror i'm embarrassed that i didn't
know better 25 years ago
but now that she's got fu money and gets
royalty checks every week a fat donation
to make herself feel better is no
problem
kaufman adds the casting wasn't a
conscious decision based on their race
but on their chemistry with each other
which is why the role of chandler did
not go to mr t
he would have been a great phoebe though
now previously kaufman's co-producer
kevin bright defended the casting
choices adding quote i would have been
insane not to hire those six actors what
can i say i wish lisa was black
who's lisa
anyway well he won't be working in
hollywood again
but the idea of casting shows based on
race rarely works isn't that how we got
kamala
[Applause]
but
it's true it would be nice to have more
black characters on tv i mean god i love
the cosby show
shout out to america's dad
[Laughter]
jim
jim it's like
white with the white race is the only
one that has this new heredity sin
it's like
we all have to now like apologize for
just being for our pigment
i know i guess black characters matter i
didn't know but
you know
i knew black lives matter but now black
characters yeah yes
and look if they're going to be doling
out money like you showed cosby before
we should all get money first you know
from the creators of cosby going hey
listen this is america's dad you tricked
us
[Applause]
okay look even if they added some black
characters i still would have never
watched one episode of that show so it
doesn't matter
i wasn't going to tune in because of it
you're more of a seinfeld guy
neither no no yeah yeah just you don't
have friends you know whatever haircut
they had that everyone out went out and
got it i mean
what is that yeah it's exactly yeah
it's awful yes that's true i forgot
about whenever jennifer anderson got a
haircut that everybody got everybody got
even the guys too you know
yeah
everyone's like i'm like chandler i'm
like who the hell is chandler yeah you
know what i mean i don't want to hang
out with that guy that thinks he's like
chandler
i just like looking behind the scenes
and seeing everything on their shelves
when i used to watch friends it's weird
you used to like kind of believe that
they were real and that they were really
your friends cat right
so easy to just make them because you
feel like you're supposed to like yeah
of course i feel bad there was no but
nobody follows up like okay
so which character would you have
replaced with a black person
yes which of these people that you hired
are you gonna you know throw under the
bus saying nope actually that would be
better if it was a black person playing
it instead of this specific person and
of course she doesn't obviously mean it
of course she doesn't regret friends
being exactly what it was because
otherwise she wouldn't just have a spare
you know four mil to just throw it's
because of friends
right
you know i mean and then if let's say
she goes you know what i should have
cast a black person in the role of the
guy that at central perk and then it'd
be like oh
serving white people
tom
it seems like everything now is getting
the statue treatment right sitcoms are
getting the statute treatment founding
fathers winston churchill everything
white is uh you have to be evil because
it's original sin and you can't wash it
off like you because you i mean
i feel like you're the expert being a
racist
that you could
well she is trying to wash it off greg
the funny thing about this is the
the endowment that she put up the money
for it's called the marta f kaufman
professorship for african american
studies if she she says she's guilty but
she's not so guilty that she doesn't put
her big fat white name in front of that
is so funny
that's so funny that's right
it's like
here's my money i'm your white god
that's it there's going to be a black
professor at that school that has to
have the marta f kaufman name in front
of their title and yes and then and then
they're going to that the professor is
going to ask that it be removed
you don't realize that the person marta
kaufman is white and gave us friends
which had no black people they're going
what's going on
they gave she gave us four million
dollars blood money
and it's african-american studies why
not uh tv production like this is the
whole thing give it give some jobs yeah
right like get him in the industry
kennedy what do you make of this story i
think they should have called it the
stokely carmichael
professorship you know exactly represent
and be real but you're absolutely right
what a narcissist
and
should mel brooks apologize for making
blazing saddles you know everyone who
who made art or comedy that couldn't be
made today should they be apologizing
for it absolutely not that's the first
thing that you learn in the art of the
deal you never apologize for anything
yes
you do
you you got to admit though that we will
be apologizing for this whole show
20 years maybe 10 years from now
15. i won't be alive
oh you mean when you finally out
yourself is it communist yes exactly
coming up
more green evangelism that relies on
threats and vandalism
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else